we love having him around doing good
yeah he's doing really good
rob kardashian's good all right good at
trolling his big sister
kim it's always so much fun the mom of
four got
schooled by her little bro after posting
this pic to instagram over the weekend
that's a fully glammed up kim rocking a
gray skim's tank top and
matching underwear while holding her
family's dog sushi
the caption say hello to my little
friend
which of course is a clear nod to this
moment
from the 1983 al pacino crime drama
scarface
well rob quickly noticed the reference
and hid up the comments to shut down his
sis
like only siblings can rob wrote quote
you never even seen scarface stop
playing
nice one gotta love a little friendly
family jab
i'm doing totally fine so the skim's
designer didn't reply to rob's comment
but their sister khloe kardashian did
telling rob to step away from the phone
rob's doing great he really is the 33
year old arthur george sock designer
took a step back from the spotlight in
2017 after season 13 of the famous
family's hit reality show
but his relatives have kept e.t up to
date on his status over the years
he's doing terrific robert's good yeah
he's working out and eating
good and so he's on a good path right
now
lately rob seems to be upping his game
and presents on social media
posting more pics online i mean
he's even posted a few selfies guys i
just want rob to do what's best for him
and what makes him happy and if that
makes him happy then we will all support
him
rob recently returned from a family
getaway for kylie's 23rd
birthday he captioned a series of shots
from the vacay quote
most beautiful trip of my life with the
fam happy birthday kylie jenner
love you thank you in april rob made a
rare cameo on keeping up with the
kardashians to celebrate his daughter
dreams
third birthday try and blow all of those
out
wow get down one more
and in july coco opened up about the
possibility of rob returning to keeping
up with the kardashians
during a chat with siriusxm hits one's
the morning mash-up
like my brother's coming back around
like he's feeling
comfortable so i think he just you know
started a whole new season so here we go